oh
my God
he's down he's still don't move
intense body camera footage shows a
shootout in Utah that leads a 36 year
old man dead and an officer injured
oh seven four I'm hit seven four I'm hit
on June 6th Ogden Utah dispatch received
a 9-1-1 call from a woman saying Brian
Simonton was violating a protective
order so he just kind of showed up
unannounced and I know he's like hit
rock rock bottom I feel bad for him but
I cannot have him here the caller told
dispatch she was simonton's ex-wife and
needed police assistance in removing him
from her apartment complex
my ex-husband
has
I'm just going to say I do have a
protective order on him
I don't want to press charges but he has
he's trying to leave his dog with me
he's homeless hasn't were to go on the
dog is very sick
and he refuses to leave unless I take
the dog I've asked somebody's
um
at this point I need to have an officer
come and let him know that he's
trespassing and then I also need to have
an officer take this dog somewhere where
he can be taken care of the caller can
be heard telling dispatch Simonton is
known to carry weapons specifically a
gun
to carry any weapons
um he's been known to like what knives
guns uh guns
will he cooperate with officers when
they get there
I Pro he I
I'm scared about how this is going to
turn out to be honest with you she also
notes he's made suicidal comments before
has he ever given any sort of method
um this is what if he has a gun because
he I don't know when he's telling the
truth or lying and
if he does have a gun that's what he
said he was going to blow his head off
and
has he ever attempted before
um not that I'm aware of he's he said it
a second 9-1-1 call then comes in from
someone else at the apartment complex
reporting Simonton will not leave the
property and is threatening others yeah
we have a gentleman here that needs to
be removed from the property known to
have guns he's yelling at me right now
so where is he at the apartment yeah
he's in front of building one next to
the dog park
do you see a gun now
uh I don't but the the residents
the resident that lives here has a
protective order against him and he will
not leave
I asked him to leave he won't leave
and she said he's known to have guns and
knives and he's yelling
yeah he's yelling at me come over here
boy I'll beat your ass right now
simonton's ex-wife then calls 9-1-1 a
second time tell me exactly what
happened
um I have my ex-husband here that I have
a protective order on he's threatening
people
busy shooting
I'm sorry
um I need an officer here right away
body camera video later shows the first
Ogden officer arriving on the scene
noting almost immediately that Simonton
has a weapon step it up he just pulled a
gun all units he's got a gun in his
right hand he's a 7-4 drop the weapon
now
drop the weapon
he's coming at me with an 88 in his
right hand the officer can be heard
yelling for Simonton to drop the gun
drop the weapon now
drop the weapon
he's pointing the firearm at me step it
up
drop the firearm now
or where are you at
come into the complex go to the left
he's in the parking lot with the gun as
other officers arrive on the scene the
first officer describes where Simonton
is within the complex within seconds
Simonton fires his weapon at the first
officer
drop the firearm now
foreign
I'm on the opposite side drop the
firearm
[Applause]
s
I can't get a shot on him right now he's
behind about five cars
drop the fire
[Applause]
upper
drop it
stop it
body camera video from other officers
shows their arrival on the scene
to the west of the lot
where are you in relation to your car
on the opposite side
foreign
gunfire erupts
where is he
right here
he's lifting his gun up at
he's shooting he's shooting footage from
a third officer shows the same moments
from a different angle
white tank top white hat
right here
he's lifting his gun at that
hey
gravy
swing it down
yup yup slowing down
[Applause]
foreign
do you see him no he fled back towards
uh 7-4 during this time the first
officer is shot and injured
so tired he's running he's behind
building one
he's gonna be going that way that way
cut him off
oh 7-4 I'm hit seven four I'm hit
[Applause]
oh
shoot oh shoot get in the house get in
the house as more and more officers
arrive on the scene they rush to help
the injured officer
wait wait
[Applause]
the Google
tourniquet meanwhile the shootout
continues
drop it now
can you see him he still has the gun
careful caught fire
up her hair over here he has a Godzilla
[Applause]
what are you guys
he's over here slaying down okay he's
down hold on
what's up
this body camera video shows the scene
from another officer's perspective
[Applause]
he still has the gun
careful
watch your Crossfire over here over here
Crossway
[Applause]
he's he's over here slaying down okay
he's down hold on okay
multiple officers then approached
Simonton from another angle
[Applause]
pants
Simonton was pronounced dead on the
scene he had previous domestic violence
convictions and two protective orders
against him at the time of his death
investigators recovered a 45 Long Colt
revolver near simonton's body and say
security camera video caught him
reloading the weapon the officer injured
in the shooting was taken to the
hospital where he underwent surgery he's
since been released and is recovered
officials later determined eight
officers fired their weapons during the
incident the shooting is still under
investigation and once complete the
results will be handed over to the Weber
County Attorney's Office reporting for
long crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie